- So, President Biden rescinded
the Trump executive orders
that basically sought
to ban TikTok and WeChat
in the United States, which,
if you're watching this,
that probably would
have affected your life.
So the thing is, the
Trump executive orders
never went into effect.
Judges in multiple lawsuits
had issued injunctions
that prevented those executive orders
from going into effect.
And basically, those executive orders
were sort of unworkable,
because they singled
out specific companies.
But TikTok and WeChat
are not out of the woods.
Replacing the Trump executive orders
are the Biden executive orders
that don't single out
a particular company,
but instead purport to look at
the national security interest
related to all these apps.
So, if they are harvesting data
for national security issues,
potentially they might still be shut down
even under the Biden administration.
So, we'll probably see TikTok in court.